so you and a few people in the squadron
either detected ufos on your instruments
or saw them directly
tell me the full story of these ufo
sightings
and uh to the smallest technical details
because i love those i'll do my best
so
we returned from and when i say we i
mean my not my squadron but vfa11 the
red rippers uh i was a
a somewhat junior pilot at the time i
joined them on deployment 2012
where they had been already out there
for about six months or so
um
operating in the vicinity of afghanistan
uh i joined them and then we we flew
back and still as a relatively new guy
we came back and we entered what's
considered a maintenance phase where we
slow down the tactical flying a bit
kind of recuperate
do some maintenance on the aircraft and
our particular model of the f-18 the lot
the lot number
was plumbed
for
the particular things that were needed
to upgrade the radar from what's known
as the abg-73 to the apg-79
and the apg-73 is a mechanically
scanned array radar uh
it's a you know perfectly fine radar but
the ace of radar is kind of a you know
magnitude jumping capability kind of a
an analog digital kind of mindset so got
it so it's a leap to digital
uh avg 73 so i mean are these things on
a carrier like what are we talking about
here this is as big as a radar yeah so
this is actually the radar it's in the
f-18 itself
okay so when you say that we're chosen
this is to test
uh the upgrade to the new the 79 abg 79.
less of an uh test and more of just hey
it's your turn to get the upgrade like
we're all going to these better radars
um they were building ones off the off
the line with the new radar but we were
this weird transitionary squadron in the
middle that transitioned from the older
ones to the new ones
but it's not particularly rare to fly
with different types of radar because in
the and we call the fleet replacement
squadron essentially the training ground
for the f-18 you have all sorts of f-18s
with different radar so
you are used to having multiple ones but
in the actual deployable
combat squadron
we upgraded and when we upgraded we saw
that there were objects on the radar
that we were seeing the next day in in
this with this new radar that weren't
there with the old radar and these were
sometimes you know the same day you
might go on two flights the one in the
morning might be with the older radar
the one the evening with the new radar
and you and you'd see the objects with
the with the new radar and that's not
overly surprising in some sense uh they
are more sensitive uh perhaps they're
not filtering out everything they should
be yet or perhaps there's some other
type of error
uh maybe it needs to be calibrated
whatever it was relatively new and we
were somewhat used to there being
software problems with these types of
things occasionally just like anything
else
and so okay maybe this is a radar
software malfunction we're getting some
false tracks as we call them
um
what were you seeing
and so what we would see are
representations of the object so this is
off of our radar we're not seeing a
visual image here this is kind of like
what's being displayed to us almost like
in a gaming fashion right like our the
icon right so the icon is showing us hey
something is there and here's the
parameters i can understand about it so
this is in the cockpit there's a display
that's showing
um some visualization with the radar is
detecting correct
and there's two different ways to do
that the first one is like the actual
data like the radar where
um
i am
it's showing me the data kind of as if
it's in front of me and i'm selecting
those contacts and there's another
screen called the situational awareness
page and that's kind of a god's eye view
that brings all that data into one spot
and so
i'm going to talk about this from the sa
page from the situational awareness page
versus the individual radar ones because
it's easier but okay so sorry to linger
on that so the individual displays are
like first person
and then the essay
is
when you say god's eye view is like from
the top integration of all that
information
as if it's looking down onto the earth
yes is that a good way to summarize it
is but for the aviator it's slightly
different because those two radar
displays i talked about are at the
bottom of that display
is kind of representable where i am and
so i see what's in front of me got it
whereas the situational awareness page
uh the aircraft is located in the center
of that
and then i all around me you know
based off of the data link and wherever
i'm getting information from
i can see that whole where page i can
see all the situation so
i'm going to kind of talk about this
from the situational awareness page
which is a top-down view just to kind of
frame our minds instead of jumping
around
and so what we would see out there is
we'd see these indications that
something would be there and they would
have a track file
that track file that thing that
represents the object has a line coming
out of it and that represents that's
called the target aspect indicator
um and there's some tracking from the
radar correct so it's showing you where
the object's going this is all pretty
cool that the radar can do all this so
radar locks in on the different objects
and attracts them over time correct
that's coming from the radar that's like
built-in feature
okay cool out there we're seeing it yes
we don't have to necessarily like pull
things into our
our tracker in some sense right like
it's all out there and then we can kind
of choose the highlight on stuff or to
kind of focus in on it more so uh but
the information should all be out there
and so we'd see that target aspect
indicator that that line on a typical
aircraft you know it would kind of look
like this it'd be coming out and it
would go steady and if they turn you you
know it would be like
when you see them turn right like it's
not magic but this object they would the
target aspect would kind of
be like all over the place like kind of
randomly in the 360 degrees you know
from that top-down view that line would
be
in a place so kind of you know is it
unable to determine the target aspect is
it stationary you know and that's just
how it puts it out and it's not used to
seeing it so i'm not saying that's
necessarily super weird but it was
different than what we were used to
seeing because we weren't used to seeing
stationary objects out there very much
um and what was also interesting is that
these weren't just stationary
on a zero wind day right these are
stationary at twenty thousand feet 15
000 feet
500 feet
you know with with the wind blowing you
know
and so much like the sea you know when
we're up there fighting it affects
everything we consider the wind when
we're you know shooting missiles when
we're flying or fuel considerations it's
like operating you know in that volume
of air like the ocean everything's going
with the current
and so anything that doesn't go with the
current you know is immediately
kind of identifiable and strange and
that's why these were initially
strangers because they would be
stationary against the wind so if you
had something like a good drone
in the windy conditions what would that
look like would it it would not come off
as stationary would it sort of float
about kind of thing no i think what the
drone technology we have today they
could stay within a pretty tight
location well i meant like dji drone not
like cons i'm saying like generically
speaking i would not i'm not a military
drone no i have a dji drone myself even
and you know maybe not 100 knots but if
that thing's in 30 or 40 not wins you
know
the amount of
distance it's going to be kind of doing
one of these like that change is not
something i'm going to detect from maybe
many miles away interesting so it could
look very stationary
but that wasn't necessarily and what's
interesting about this story is that
there's not like the one smoking gun
right you have to kind of look at
everything and that's what you know i
don't like about um
the department of defense and just
generally people's take on this is that
everything is kind of based around a
single image you know or that one case
but a lot of interestingness comes from
the duration or the time it's been out
there how they're interacting relative
to other objects out there and you don't
get that information when you just look
at a frame for a second you know
everyone kind of bites off on the shiny
object but so you yourself or from your
particular slice of things you've
experienced and seen directly or
indirectly you've kind of built up an
intuition about what
the things that were being seen i want
to go that far i've just been able to
you know eliminate some some variables
because of how long i've observed it so
like you said yes can a drone stay in a
particular position against the wind
like that certainly but i don't think it
can do that and then go point eight mach
for four hours after that you know and
so when you when you look at outside of
that once that moment in time then it
eliminates a lot of the potential things
it could be at least from my perspective
so what kind of stuff did you see yeah
in the instruments we'd see them flying
um in patterns kind of racetrack
patterns or circular patterns or just
going kind of straight east
i
occasionally see them supersonic 1.1 1.2
mach but typically 0.6 to 0.8 mach just
for
extremely extended periods of time you
know essentially all the time
and this is airspace where there's not
supposed to be anything else at all um
and it's pretty far out there it starts
10 miles off the coast goes like 300
miles can you say the location that
we're talking about off the coast of
virginia beach
got it and so nobody is supposed to be
out there
it's possible for people to be there
it's not necessarily restricted but it's
well monitored and we're out there every
day all day and so you know people know
to stay clear if a cessna goes bumbling
in there everyone's going to know about
it fa is going to you know call him out
he's going to tell us about it so
um
concursions happen not a big deal but um
they're pretty rare honestly because
everyone knows area and we've been
operating there for decades and what are
the trajectories at 0.6 to 0.8 mach that
these objects were taking
typically they would be in some type of
circular pattern or kind of racetrack
pattern when they were at those beads or
i just see them kind of it wasn't always
like a mechanical flight
description and when i say that i mean
like an autopilot is going to be
just very precise right it's going to be
locked on straight and whereas i could
see an airplane i could tell if the
pilot's flying it right because it's not
going to be perfect
the computer's not controlling it and
these seemed more like that not that
they were imprecise but that they were
even much more erratic than that so like
it wasn't like a straight line in a turn
it was just kind of like a
you know weird drift like that in that
direction you know so it wasn't
controlled by a dumb computer or uh
no disrespect to computers so it wasn't
controlled by autopilot kind of
technology that's not the sense that i
got
so how many people have seen them in the
squadron
so how many times were they seen how
many
um
were there times when there's multiple
objects once we started seeing on the
radar enough and we would get close
enough we'd actually see them on our
fleer as well so our advanced targeting
uh pod uh it's essentially a infrared
camera that we use for targeting mostly
in the air-to-surface environment
we don't use it in the air arena it's
just not that good of a tool uh frankly
but um we would see ir energy emitting
from that location where the radar was
dropping us off so you know the radar
we'd lock onto the object and our
sensors would all look there and so then
we could see that it's looking at that
right piece of sky but
there's energy actually coming from
there so now we start thinking that okay
maybe not radar malfunctions maybe more
maybe something is physically here of
course and then people started to try to
fly by and see it at this point
you know i would say maybe 80 to 90
percent of our squadron have probably
seen one of these on the radar at this
point everyone was aware of it
there was small communication i think
between squadrons of the same area that
had the same radar so i knew it wasn't
just our squadron for whatever strange
reason
because they would be other squadrons
would be out there and we would talk to
them like hey like careful there's an
object are you aware of that you know so
like they would be aware of it
and then of course people would want to
go see what they look like right so
people would try to fly by i try to fly
by him i like how that's in of course
of course of course you don't want to
fly by it so you know
there's an uh there's a argument against
that kind of perspective that maybe the
thing is dangerous so maybe we don't but
perhaps that's part of the reason you
want to fly by it is to understand
better what it is if it's a threat we
have a lot of context now that we did it
back then you know and so it was still a
hey is this a balloon is this a drone
you know at a certain point and we're
also aware of you know potential
intelligence gathering operations that
could be going on
we're up there flying our tactics we're
emitting uh we're practicing our ew
you know we're turning at particular
times like there's stuff that can be
learned it's not a secret and you know
countries keep different fishing vessels
and what not in international waters off
there so it's not exactly a secret that
uh we're being observed out there so to
think that a foreign hospital or a
foreign nation would want to um
you know somehow intercept information
whether that's
our radar signals or jamming
capabilities to try to
break that down or understand it better
be ready for that next fight
i mean
that's what that's what scares me about
this scenario because
we didn't jump right to aliens or ufos
we thought you know this is a radar
malfunction we need to be aware of it's
a safety issue and then
you know this could be a a tactical
problem right here because
everything we do is based off a crypto
and and locate you know locations
everything is classified we do out there
right and so over time if you gather
enough data about those fights and just
monitor them forever just like some
nations do with other
pieces of technology or software
they could probably learn a lot so we
have to be cognitive effect and defend
against it
so what can you say about the
other characteristics of these objects
like shape
size
texture
luminosity
how else do you describe object is there
something that could be said so you said
like there's the tecton radar step one
now you have clear images that can give
you a sense that it's actually a
physical object what else can be said
about those physical objects so
eventually someone did see one with
their own eyeballs
multiple people and it and they saw it
in a kind somewhat interesting way
the object presented itself at
the exact altitude and geographic
location of the entry points into our
working areas
so we enter at a very specific point at
a certain altitude and people leave the
areas at the same point at a lower
altitude
probably one of the busiest pieces of
sky on the eastern seaboard
so two jets from my squadron went out
and they went flying and they entered
the area and one of these objects went
right between the aircraft so they're
flying in formation and the object went
between the aircraft they went between
the object i think i don't think that
the object was moving i don't think it
aggressively went at them i think it was
located still there and then they flew
through it
but they didn't have it on their radar
and that would
i think the radar might have been
malfunctioning i don't know that for
sure i would like to look into it but my
supposition is that if their radar was
malfunctioning it would make sense that
they wouldn't avoid the object that was
there because they knew these were
physical at that point
um and we we would go up to these
objects all the time time and try to see
them we couldn't see them and we didn't
know what it was um was it that were
they just not there or being fooled was
something happening were they were they
moving dropping out to the last minute
you know we're going by pretty quick so
it's difficult to tell
um but perhaps if his radar wasn't
working he wasn't receiving energy from
the jet
and the jet of course didn't know that
it was there and so whatever the case
was they flew right by and they
described it just as a dark gray or
black cube
um inside a clear translucent sphere and
the kind of the apex of the cube were
touching the inside of that sphere
that's an image that's haunting so what
do they think it is what did they think
at that moment uh that they is it just
this kind of cloud of uncertainty that
that they're just describing a geometric
object
it's not on radar so it's unclear what
it is
um yeah what was
uh the
any kind of other description they've
had of it in terms of
the intuition from a pilot's perspective
you know you have to kind of identify
what a thing is
to answer the first part they they
actually canceled the flight and came
back because they were you know it's
like if there's one of these out here
we're almost hitting them and it's right
there then um you know perhaps we need
to get a different jet with better radar
but so they came back and they're in
their gear and they're they're talking
to the front desk and talking to skipper
and like hey we almost hit one of those
damn things out there and this kind of
was one of those
kind of slight watershed moments where
we all were kind of like all right like
this is a serious deal now yeah you know
maybe it was a maybe we thought they
were
balloons or drones or malfunctions or
maybe we thought it was fine but the end
of the day if we're going to hit one of
these things then we need to you know we
need to take care of the situation
and that's actually when we started
submitting hazard reports or hazard reps
to the naval through the naval aviation
safety
um
kind of communication networks and it's
you know it's not like a big proactive
thing where people can go investigate
it's more of a data collection mechanism
so that you can kind of share that
aggregate data and make sure things are
progressing
so it wasn't a mechanism that would
result in action being taken but we were
hoping to at least get the message out
to whomever was maybe running a
classified program that we were not
aware of or something like that that hey
like you could kill somebody here like
you've you've grown too big for your
britches here take a step back
so that was that was our concern at that
point that's kind of where we were
thinking this was going
what's the protocol for shooting at a
thing
was was uh
was there a concern that it's a direct
threat not just surveillance but
a thing that could be yeah a threat at
least from my perspective like that
never really crossed into my mind i
thought it was potentially intelligence
you know failure that could be being
watched and information gathered
but i didn't think that it was something
that would
proactively engage me in a hostile
manner it wouldn't really make sense
either too
it would be shocking to like have one of
these objects take out an f-18 but
there's no real tactical advantage other
than fear perhaps
that's psychological yeah
i've learned a lot about
the
psychological warfare in ukraine this is
a big part of the war in terms of when
you talk about siege warfare about war
wars that last for many years
for many months and then perhaps could
extend two years but yes
um it didn't seem
it didn't fit your conception of a
threatening
entity correct
so looking back now from the all the
pieces of data you've integrated
you've personally added what do you
think it could be
i don't know i don't know what it could
be i think we've been able to categorize
it successfully into a few buckets
we've been able to say that you know
this could be us technology that
someone
put in the wrong piece of sky or you
know perhaps was developed and tested in
an inappropriate spot by someone that
wasn't paying best practices is there uh
sorry to interrupt is there
a sort of modularity to the way
the the military operates to where it's
possible for one branch not to know
about the tests of another yeah i think
it's perfectly reasonable to think that
that could occur right and so if we just
make that assumption we can integrate
that into our analysis here and just say
okay but at the point we're at now you
know we have to assume that that's not
the case right with everything that's
been going on and the statements have
been made and the hearings
i think that if it was a
non-communication issue um we're in big
trouble at this point
what about it being an object from
another nation from china from russia or
even one of our allies perhaps right
maybe
you know
i don't think it's um controversial to
say that our allies could be gathering
information about us or anything of that
nature but that would be an extreme case
but i think it's just important to say
right to not just say russia or china
and just call them the bad guys and
assume that if they don't have it no one
can do it um and so from my perspective
you know anyone else anyone else it
doesn't necessarily need to be a foreign
power it could be a non-government
entity perhaps although i think that's
very unlikely but again these are these
are things you must consider if you kind
of throw everything
everything other than the us under under
scrutiny
but you know from what
has been reported and the behaviors that
have been seen
it would be
i would expect to see remnants of that
technology elsewhere in the economy
there seems to be too many
things that require
advanced technology that would be
beneficial commercially as well as in
other military applications for it to be
completely locked away by
one of our competitors now i could see
us perhaps locking something away if
we're already in the lead and having it
to
pull out as needed but for someone
that's perhaps in a power struggle and
they're in second place
they might be more aggressive with the
development of different types of
technology willing to accept bigger
risks
do you think it could be natural
phenomena that we don't yet understand
i think that there are a number of
things that this is going to be right i
don't think there's one thing at the end
of the day but i certainly think that
that is part of what some of this could
be i don't think it's what we were
seeing on the east coast uh and i don't
think it is related to the roosevelt
incident or i'll even go out and say the
nimitz incident but what's the roosevelt
incident the roosevelt incident
typically referred to as the gimbal
and or the go fast video and then the
nimitz is from uh
with the david fravor has uh witnessed
directly and spoken about
we'll talk about that as well i'd just
love to get your um
your sort of uh interpretation of those
incidents but
yeah so in this particular case natural
phenomena could be a part of the picture
but you're saying not the whole picture
yes
yes and we can't discount it oh the
other thing is what about the failure of
pilot eyesight
like
sort of
some deep mixture of actual direct
vision
human vision system failure
and like psychology
like
um seeing something weird
and then filling in the gaps
because in order to make sense of the
weird i've tried to expose myself to
a scenarios like that that i don't
necessarily think are right but i've
explored them to see if they could have
some truth and one example is let's
imagine a scenario where we're seeing
these objects every day off the east
coast
i can imagine a technology or an
operation where you had some type of
traditional propulsion system operating
drones in order to gather data like we
had discussed
and
i could i could envision a clever enough
adversary that could perhaps destroy or
somehow remove these objects and replace
them with new objects essentially when
we're not looking right and that
accounts for the
large uh airborne time and so i i
explore options like that and i try to
see you know what what evidence and
assumptions need to be made in order to
prove or disprove that
and you know
you would need so much infrastructure
you know you need some you need so many
assets and so i try to explore some of
those fallacies and some of those
concerns and as aviators we're trained
into many uh
like actual physical like eyesight and
kind of illusion uh training so like at
nighttime flying there's so many things
that can happen flying with false
horizons and so we receive hours of
training on that type of of stuff but
this just falls outside the category
from my perspective what was the
visibility conditions when in the times
when people were able to see it and then
we
we just earlier discussed complete
nighttime
darkness
um in this case was was it during the
day
it was a perfectly clear day that
that particular incident yep
in a world that's full of mystery i have
to ask what do you think
is the possibility that
it's not of this earth origin
i like the term non-human intelligence
in a sense
because
again there's so much there's a lot of
assumptions in there that
may cause us go down the wrong roads
it could you know these could be
something that our weather phenomena of
earth right or something else that is
just something we don't understand i
can't imagine right now that's still of
this earth
if we consider
extraterrestrials or something that came
from a physical place far away in space
time
you know that leads us to some detection
assumptions that we would need to make
and so i just try to not categorize it
under anything and just say hey is this
demonstrating intelligence
and start from there as a single object
what can we learn about it kinematically
how it's performing what does that mean
for its energy source what does that
mean for the g-forces inside and then
step it out a level and say okay how are
these interacting with our fighters if
they are how are they interacting with
the weather and their environment how
are they interacting with each other so
can we look at these and how they're
acting perhaps as a swarm
especially off the east coast where this
is happening all the time with multiple
objects right and so we might be able to
determine some things about their maybe
you know center capabilities or the
areas of focus you know if we can
determine uh how they're working in
conjunction with each other but you know
seeing one little flash of an object uh
doesn't provide that type of insight
um but we have the systems4 but and it's
kind of made on irony but it's it's a
fact of life the reality that many of
these well-deployed highly capable
systems are held under the military
umbrella which makes it difficult to
provide that data for scientific
analysis
so there's probably a lot more data on
these objects that's not being
that's not made available probably even
within the military for analysis i think
so yeah i think there's a lot of data
that could be made available
and you know that's one of the reasons
why
you know i've been engaged with the
american institute of aeronautics and
astronautics to build you know a large
resources of cross-domain expertise so
that if or when that data is available
or that there's additional analysis
needed you know we can spin up those
teams and make that analysis
you